developing here at five new information
regarding the death of a cyclist and a
minivan passenger in the east valley
who's accused of intentionally
harassing pedestrians police arrested
the driver suspected in the case
and they've also identified the woman
who was killed while she was riding her
bike
as now 56-year-old michelle weisman now
this all happened sunday on
hollywood boulevard near sahara 8 news
now reporter kristen drummond is live
from there with what she learned
happened
just prior to that tragedy kristen
denise a deadly attack on a cyclist
leaves two people
dead this weekend spray paint on the
street here behind me
reveals the aftermath of this crime from
broken pieces from a van police suspect
was involved in the murder police
arrested rodrigo
cruz and he appeared in court this
afternoon he's accused
of driving the van a police report
reveals he and two others
in the car were driving from the view an
area of vegas valley in hollywood
now cruz estimates he was speeding
between 50 and 60 miles per hour
when the man identified as geo decided
to sit on the van's
window ledge police say geo attempted to
hit a couple walking on the sidewalk and
missed and then
pushed a cyclist identified as michelle
weisman at the same time police say a
witness tells them the front side of the
van
hit the bicycle and that caused weissman
to fall over the handlebars and die
geo also fell out of the van and skid
150 feet before hitting a street light
now this overall situation is causing
concern among the cycling community
and people who exercise around here
that could have been me because i always
go at the sunrise and yesterday i was
just being a little lazy and i didn't go
until 8 30 so it was like an hour after
that happened
police say cruz continued driving home
which was about four miles away
the arrest report states he never
stopped because he was scared since he
was on parole
and did not think geo was hurt cruz is
charged with violating his parole
open murder and not stopping at the
scene of an accident he will be back in
court
this wednesday police say weissman was
wearing a helmet
police were able to find the van and
they say that
damage to the front right side passenger
side
indicates that it was involved in this
murder
reporting live in the east valley
kristen drummond 8 news now